make way for Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports
college basketball analyst and you can
hear him on the Doug Gottlieb show on
Fox Sports Radio good morning Doug good
morning you know it's interesting I feel
like edu bras Dacus is trying to do the
opposite for Michigan the Zion is doing
for Duke like is e bras day Michigan is
like the most likeable program with John
Beilein and just find a way that they
lose guys the pros doesn't matter and
yet they're there right back in the Big
Ten championship game yet he it's like
one shot and he throws up the money
every time he gets a shoddy throws up
the money side he's Johnny Manziel he's
like trying to make Michigan unlikable
meanwhile his I wimps and I love him I
want him to be my son I love him and I'm
it makes me love Duke it is impossible
to not like I don't know anyone who
doesn't thoroughly enjoy the science and
experience but we want to have comps
with Zion Williamson and I always you
know I think we look at his body and
then we go okay he's Charles Barkley or
Larry Johnson but his game is unique
it's it's different than those players
so when it comes to Zion why do we keep
looking for well he reminds me of
because that's what we do
that's what that's a scout state because
something somebody has to have done it
before right in order to in order to
think and I'll just tell you is like I
thought other Charles was great on your
show but remember Charles if he came out
now would be a four or five be a power
for their play small ball Center and
he'd be even better and this Mike thing
about draymond Green who was fat in
college right and played the four in
college everybody thought well he's
gonna have to be a small forward and
then Golden State he lost weight and
Golden State found a great role for him
so Zion is a combination of Roger Rodney
Rogers he's got a little bit of LeBron
you got a little bit of LeBron in terms
of just incredible downhill athlete
obviously barkley but then you know
here's the position he's gonna play is
going to be draymond Green position only
he's far more athletic um you know and
he showed me ability to be a really good
passer which is the thing
draymond Green does best and you know
draymond Green camp can't make a shot
now I mean think about design
Williamson in that role and I heard you
talking to your completely right the
thing that you love about zionists he
doesn't have to have to follow a plays
run for him in order to take over a game
whereas RJ Barrett he can't do it any
other way
and I'm not sure he's actually good
enough at the highest level the NBA to
do it that way so I he's a he's a
powerful slash small ball Center which
whatever evokes everybody's looking for
in the NBA and then yeah you compare
kind of those body types of the Roddy
Rodgers the there's a little Larry
Johnson I saw him that Louisville game
and he's he's got great feet and feel in
the low Posey so if you guys have as
well all right let's look at some of
these matchups here is there any foe
outraged by you with but now okay you
know me you know me I'm bitter Betty I'm
not usually find a bunch of stuff like
do I do I think do I think you know
Clemson and NC State are probably better
than Belmont in Temple like yeah but you
know I've friend out these like one of
the world's greatest guys mister
Philadelphia bobbies last game and like
why not throw a bone to Belmont and say
that the net actually matters no this
year
I swear and part of it is we got helped
out because we had some bids deals you
know we had we had the Atlantic ten you
know VCU lose and lost their best player
to injury we don't know if he'll play we
had a couple other you know the the
Mountain West
you know also gave us some you know kind
of crazy screwy ending and so we had a
couple of bid steals which ended up what
was a super weak bubble became a decent
bubble indiana's good enough to be there
you can't lose 1213 games playing the
NCAA tournament
NC State you know that they didn't beat
any of the good teams in the ACC and
Clemson just had a disappointing year
after surprising you last year so I'm
not I'm not really bad for any all three
of those how many teams have what you
think is legitimate chance to win it all
you nailed it you're on fire like six
right yeah like I and then you know you
throw in the it's like it's like spades
like I guess I got five or the possible
or six mean Carolina Duke Kentucky
Gonzaga Tennessee
you know I genius anyone is there ever
going to be a more watched won 16 games
in Virginia against our web and by the
way Garden web is not bad and probably
shouldn't be as 16 seems like the low
seeds are kind of scurrying some of
these things but I would say you know
that's that's kind of your general
working list and I just I saw I called
the Michigan Michigan State game on
radio and I do think that Michigan State
that a little screwed not in being that
the two seed where you can't put you put
them in Dukes bracket but more you play
them on a Thursday you know them you put
them on a Thursday after playing that
that that incredible war I would make
sure you to play them on a Friday but I
don't think that Michigan State or
Michigan have the horses to win it all
but it wouldn't stunned me if somehow
they found one of these found a way to
get in there and then you know there's
the I actually think Nevada is really
good I'm you know and I think I think
Buffalo was under seeded I think they're
really good means you look for
Cinderella's but I think your nails it
probably seems I can win it yeah I'm
looking at the Cinderella team and then
you start to think it's it's plural
there's a lot of Cinderella teams it
feels like and you know somebody's
getting in it always feels like somebody
sneaks into the Elite Eight that team is
going to be who wouldn't stop me if it's
Buffalo yeah me neither
it just it would not sell me now Buffalo
that the two teams that they may play
like st. John's his super super talented
with Shamari ponds and then Arizona
State Bobby Hurley's club they're gonna
play st. John's they can beat anybody I
mean they're they're just kind of
erratic they have a freshman Lou door
who's a Canadian kid who's built he's
built like a linebacker you know he can
throw in a couple of threes and he's
they have freak freak athletes on those
teams so I think Buffalo's in for a
hellacious first game but then get past
it like look buffalo is real absolutely
real you know the thing that screw this
whole thing up is Duke has had a bunch
of injuries and I don't know what
Syracuse to see it is or if they get in
if they don't be Duke & Duke was down
two players and they play them Carolina
gets a 1 seed because they beat Duke but
Duke didn't have Zion either time you
know it's really interesting on the Duke
injuries and then you
Duke who we all think has a great shot
to win it but they can't shoot we have
an entire write like whom a who is a
national championship one with freshmen
and two freshmen that cannot shoot it's
really it's gonna be everybody has that
fundamental flaw and I don't feel icky
at all I picked Kentucky to win the
whole thing I was all-in on Kentucky a
couple of weeks ago and then all of a
sudden I went oh man come on
it didn't feel like they were elevating
their game although I do give credit to
John Calipari you know he has an
interior designer when when he was on
yesterday when they were interviewing
him and he had all of his former players
jerseys behind him I thought it was I
thought it was brilliant but man I was
all-in on Kentucky a couple of weeks ago
not not as much now is it that was a
that was a that was a baller move look
they have they have I'd you know look
they have like one of it's like they got
one of everything you know you got like
Tyler hero who's like their Rex Chapman
electric scorer and then you got Calvin
Johnson who did kind of an elegant score
and then kid ash the Higgins or point
guards a lockdown defender can't shoot
was like I think you've read Travis and
PGA Washington's I once a one can you
know defender and the other ones to
score I mean look I think they beat
Tennessee if if read Travis doesn't foul
out and look I got my questions about
them but and I would love to see a
rematch of Duke ran off the floor to
start the year but it was so long ago
and kind of figured it out so yeah but
look you you nailed it you got you got
six teams and there'll be a little bit
of craziness but I generally think we
know who the cream is and I'd be stunned
if we didn't have and I don't mean help
Gonzaga you know I know they lost to
Carolina and I mean and lost in
Tennessee but they beat Duke they're
gonna be right there the questions with
them in Tennessee with their backcourt
but they're loaded and they played for
national championship before so III
think we'll have a good tournament but
I'm not sure we're going to have the
number of late in the numbers sweet 16
or lead eight surprises we've had years
in the past good to talk to you Doug
thanks as always we appreciate you
what do I have to do to get in the
Continental Tire commercials will have
to do because you guys are going to be
on there in determent more than anybody
else will I have to do it can you make
10 consecutive free-throws I don't know
okay are you gonna be in the new man
with an is it in the new does the new
man cave have a low a below no ceiling
no are you gonna be at the Final Four
yeah okay
I'm gonna have a basketball hoop there I
got a ten in a row general all right I'm
going to work I'm actually I'm gonna go
drive to the gym right now you know with
me it's all mental I know and I could
you just let me play could you just let
me play like Seaton or one of those guys
in one-on-one or something left-handed
like could you give me something I could
actually do I would consider how about
you against Dan dockage Dan shut down
Jordan all right well he's the only one
to shut down yeah it may be Eddie Jordan
but not Michael Jordan but yeah you're
right docket docket shiz away a little
bit from that you know hey you shut down
Michael Jordan yeah maybe not but are
you saying that you're you're afraid of
Dan dockage I'm not playing Dan darkest
but he's an old man
Wow the last time like he steps on a
basketball court but it's always the
dress shoes on like I still play
basketball like it's okay I just don't
want to abuse my elders I respect and
doctors are great this is just a
shooting contest done Oh in a shooting
contest is that I get out you're dead
and the shooting contest sure okay all
right well maybe we can make a shoe
design by catch you Dan maybe we can
make that happen in Minneapolis all
right good and and if I win I get in the
next Continental Tire has because you
guys are gonna be on for the parklet I'm
good
I'm gonna all work on that all right I
appreciate it thank you Doug that's Doug
Gatlin Doug Gottlieb from Fox Sports for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]